the New York Times article the best part
of that article was the last part which
is one of our clients Nilla wafers you
know people in the South they love it
that's where it sells you know they put
all their money into social with us tell
us that story I know Nilla wafer did a
test and decided we're gonna go by the
way I wish I was harder I wish I was
smarter this story pisses me off to be
honest with you cuz it shows a lack of
smarts strategically for me which breaks
my heart I wasn't smart enough in the
first three and a half years of
vaynermedia to realize the way I was
gonna prove the ROI of social media was
to get a client to give me all their
budget and just it and it happened
serendipitously we had half of nillas
budget the other half was supposed to be
some contests and bullcrap stuff that
wasn't gonna work somehow that fell
through and nila said you know what you
take it so we had the entire budget and
so this is a brand that hadn't grown for
a decade flat sales this was all we did
was pictures and videos and pop micro
content when I talked about in the book
on Facebook and Pinterest mainly Twitter
as well and here we are a year later and
the business is up nine percent it's a
phenomenal success story because this
isn't about impressions
this isn't about Nielsen ratings this is
we sold a lot more stuff that's actual
business and so